hey 42 here the world is like a high
school playground depending on their
ideologies and cultures the various
countries tend to form cliques and shun
others who aren't a part of their
special gang since World War two a
handful of international alliances have
sprung up that have segregated the world
into distinct and globalized entities
each believing that they are defending
the world from evil or protecting a
certain way of life there's a UN EU WTO
UNESCO NATO cmf African Union Arab
League and that's just a tiny number of
examples every country seems to have
more alliances and treaties than they
have brands of beer it can be incredibly
complex attempting to keep up with who
likes who and which countries want to
blow each other up so which of these
high school gangs would be the most
likely instigators of World War 3 well
as current world affairs and political
tensions stand there are three obvious
scenarios that could lead the world down
the dark path of global warfare the
first instigator could be China vers the
US China desires to fully retake Taiwan
and expand its territory throughout to
the South China Sea to secure safe
channels for its fast-growing blue water
Navy and to a road America's military
grip on the region
China has even gone as far as building
artificial islands in the South China
Sea to put military bases on China's
expansion economically geographically
and militarily poses a serious threat to
the global hegemony of the u.s.
currently the only superpower America is
unlikely to sit back and let China
overtake that number one spot on the
world stage without a bit of a fight
tensions between China and the US are
increasing by the year and it could soon
blow up quite literally into World War 3
the second spark could come from you
guessed it Russia versus the US the
Russian bear wants to be seen as strong
on the global stage and that illusion of
strength was pange after the fall of the
Soviet Union
Russia deeply desires to retake lost
states such as Ukraine it also feels
constantly threatened by the growing
power and membership of NATO its largest
and most formidable opponent Putin Trump
tensions could throw the world into a
dark abyss of global war lastly the
Hermit Kingdom North Korea could
instigate World War 3 despite Kim
jong-un agreeing to denuclearization at
a summit with Trump
it's believed there are in fact 13
secret nuclear facilities in North Korea
and their recent blatant missile tests
over Japan are hardly reassuring the
world that North Korea
aren't looking to arm themselves to the
teeth with nuclear warheads then there
are a handful of other ongoing tensions
that by themselves could instigate World
War 3 such as India vs. Pakistan there's
persistent tensions with Syria and bad
blood between Iran Britain and the u.s.
some experts believe current world
tensions are greater than during the
Cold War in truth nobody can predict if
World War II will happen and if so when
it will happen but what would a third
world war look like Albert Einstein said
I know not with what weapons World War
II will be fought but World War four
will be fought with sticks and stones
indeed in a nuclear-armed world world
war free is a terrifying prospects but
could a nuclear Armageddon actually
happen yes of course it could however
it's extremely unlikely and most experts
agree that even if World War three
kicked off the chances of a nuclear
missile being launched are quite low why
the mutually assured destruction all it
would take is one ICBM to hit a NATO
country Russia or China and the full
force of America or Russia's missiles
would be launched in retaliation
basically in this scenario every
possible path leads to all world powers
being utterly annihilated within the
space of
day heads of state may seem erratic and
even stupid at times but they all
understand this essential premise you
destroy us we destroy you nuclear
weapons maybe the end game of a world
war the last desperate play of the
losing side but I don't believe they
will come at the very start most likely
there will be an instigator event
followed by a steady escalation of force
but the real question is in what form
will that force come warfare has changed
substantially since World War two the
days of trenches frontlines and armies
and even tanks are long gone a relic of
the past and modern weaponry has made
large numbers of foot soldiers less
impactful during warfare though they
will always be needed in some format we
live in a world where an operator can
sit in an air-conditioned room on the
other side of the planet and command a
drone to deliver a laser-guided hellfire
missile into a building or massive
persons killing hundreds with a single
strike we live in a world where aircraft
super carriers are equipped with
surface-to-air missiles rail guns that
can hit ground targets over 220 miles
away with incredible precision and
freakin laser guns boots on the ground
is still an essential tool for any
nation and can be utilized in a
multitude of ways but in the third world
war vast land armies would be far less
effective than they were last century
and human warfare will be more Special
Op space to use to take out
high-priority targets with skill and
precision
since nuclear weapons aren't really
usable in the real world about
destroying the entire planet navies are
the greatest weapon not world powers
have at their disposal
specifically aircraft carriers an
aircraft carrier is a formidable
floating military base that costs over
five billion pounds to build and the
running cost would make your head spin
as a result very few countries have
aircraft carriers only the UK Italy and
the US have more than one at there come
the u.s. actually has it written into
law that the naval command forces of the
Navy shall include not less than 11
operational aircraft carriers but any
Navy's immense power and immense costs
are also its greatest weaknesses in a
real-life wartime scenario any
commander-in-chief has to consider risk
and costs before sending an aircraft
carrier or destroyer fleet into the heat
of battle the problem is if they make a
tactical error and lose one or more
aircraft carriers not even America can
click its fingers and conjure up a
replacement these beer moths take over
five years to build modern super
carriers are by no means easy to attack
they are fraught with weaponry and
designed to repel enemies with ease but
if a rival state was able to engage a
carrier fleet in combat and had the
means to sink it and the results would
be devastating and a certain game
changer after all no matter how well
protected a capital ship may be all it
takes is one lucky shot from a torpedo
or an anti-ship ballistic missile like
the kind that China has recently
developed and with that one strike down
goes billions of pounds and years of
work and for some countries their only
carrier and primary means of defense
leaving the doors wide open to attack
not to mention the loss of critical
experience military personnel when ships
sink they have a nasty habit of taking
the entire crew with them when HMS hood
was sunk in 1941 1415 of a 1400 an 18
strong crew perished with her since
supercarrier engagement is
extraordinarily risky even for America
as the old adage says the bigger they
are the harder they fall they will most
likely be used exclusively for defense
in a few
to war therefore war leaders will seek a
lower-risk offensive strategy and there
is one method of warfare that is
extremely low risk and low cost but the
rewards could be immense I'm talking
about cyber warfare every major world
power has invested heavily into
state-sponsored hacking even if they
don't like to admit it because they all
know the truth and nation that can
effectively hack another during wartime
would have possibly the greatest upper
hand of all cyber warfare is at its most
terrifying when it has the power to
affect physical infrastructure and
weaponry a WikiLeaks report revealed
that the CIA has been hoarding zero-day
vulnerabilities for just about every
operating system including Android and
iOS devices zero-day vulnerabilities are
basically keys that a hacker can use to
freely gain access to a system and the
system developers in this case Google
Apple and Microsoft the world's largest
tech companies have no idea that they
exist so hence they have zero days to
react to to hack the CIA was stockpiling
the zero day keys and using them to
develop deadly cyber weapons similar to
the Stuxnet malware that artfully
infected an Iranian nuclear plant
inflicting major physical damage to its
machinery it's believed that the CIA NSA
GCHQ and mi5 have cooperated to develop
an entire suite of similar cyber weapons
to Stuxnet
unbelievably the world's for leading
Intelligence divisions don't go about
their day broadcasting the details of
their latest creations but it's believed
that they have created malware that can
infect pretty much whatever they like
for a variety of purposes all the way
from smart televisions and smart phones
used to spy on people to the on-board
computer systems of cars and trucks
which could be utilized to steer them
off the road or disable them entirely
and you just know that if the US and UK
are working on such weapons then so are
Russia and China but the most chilling
targets that these state actors could
direct their cyber weapons towards is
infrastructure the infrastructure that
enables our modern lifestyles and keeps
countries afloat from the road network
to the banks the power stations water
filtration law enforcement and health
care all run on computer software and so
in theory can be hacked and disrupted
but hackers taking down public sewer
systems or stopping consumers from being
able to use their debit cards isn't
going to take down a rival government
and win a war or visits during World War
two both the Axis and Allies ran long
and devastating strategic bombing raids
the purpose of these were to demoralize
the everyday citizens of the respective
countries to degrade their enthusiasm
for war to such a point where they would
no longer have the stomach to continue
fighting or supporting the war efforts
those bastard Nazis could never crack
the British spirit but had the Blitz
gone on for another few years who's to
say that they wouldn't have in theory
this style of attrition warfare is a
highly effective strategy for when a
nation cannot outright penetrate the
military defences of their opponents and
it's in this exact same manner that
cyber warfare would be used in World War
II cyber warfare is cheaper than carpet
bombing and can affect a substantially
higher number of people public
infrastructure is far easier to hack
than military equipment because the
computer systems our own infrastructure
are really very severely outdated or
connected to the public Internet whereas
military installations are usually
always isolated from any form of public
network which means that the only way to
hurt them is with physical access to the
facility mind you that didn't stop the
u.s. when they infected the Iranian
nuclear plant with Stuxnet
which was also isolated from the public
Internet interestingly military
facilities usually use outdated computer
systems on purpose because so long as
they aren't connected to the public
Internet they are less susceptible to
modern-day hugs and books the US
Department of Defense recently announced
that it has only just stopped using
floppy disks to store data in some of
their military facilities so this begs
the question what if a rival state is
able to do the highly improbable and
access the isolated military facilities
of its enemy then the sky is quite
literally the limit a malware could be
pre-programmed to launch nuclear weapons
when it detects that it has successfully
infected the target facility and it
could aim those weapons within the
target country's own borders effectively
forcing a nation to commit suicide
another deadly weapon that will change
the face of a third world war his drones
unmanned aerial vehicles are already
used by NATO forces to perform frequent
precision strikes on Isis strongholds in
the Middle East but what if smaller more
agile and less obvious drones were
militarized I'm talking about the drones
consumers buy to film pretty scenery
from the air drone warfare is a serious
threat that global think tanks are
getting all worked up over and for good
reason small sized military drones pose
one of the greatest threats to humanity
during both peace and war time the
United States Department of Defense is
currently working on a project called
purr dicks which aims to give every
soldier on the field a personal micro
drone these small devices could fit into
assaulters pocket and be deployed into
the air in seconds once airborne each
soldier's drone communicates with every
other drone used by the same squad and
each one taps into a single shared brain
to form a swore the swarm could
coordinate their movements in real-time
and alert each other to enemy locations
and defensive systems that could
threaten the swarm per Dex drones have
been undergoing real-world testing for
the past few years currently they're
only intended use is visual intelligence
and scouting ahead for enemies but
there's nothing to say that guns
couldn't be attached to them when
combined with artificial intelligence
driven targeting which the u.s. DoD is
also currently developing then these
armed micro drones make for an almost
unstoppable and terrifying weapon in
only a few years these swarms of drones
could be shooting down human targets and
those very targets could be chosen
automatically by a computer algorithm
inside the swarms shared brain I'm sure
not many sane people would mind if this
technology would be used to protect our
freedoms
but the ugly consequences of terrorist
organizations getting their hands on
this technology could be utterly
devastating whether World War II will be
fought with bombs missiles guns computer
viruses or drones one thing is for
certain it will be more terrifying than
ever before every major successive war
in the past two centuries has increased
in both duration and brutality we live
in a time when computer code can cause
more devastation in a nuclear weapon and
that's not something to be taken lightly
or we can hope is that the world
continues to move away from war and
towards peace but whilst you sit back
and wait for world war free you can keep
yourself busy by improving your online
security with dashlane who have kindly
sponsored this video - Lane is a
password manager that automatically
creates bulletproof passwords for all
your online accounts and also fills them
so you never have to click forgot
password ever again using the same or
similar passwords for different websites
makes it super easy for hackers to
access your entire online world but -
slang creates a unique super-strong
password for each account - Lane also
fills your credit card information
whilst online shopping so you can make
purchases without even having to fetch
your wallet and it works seamlessly
across all your devices it has a
built-in VPN with country select so you
can access any Content stay secure and
protect your privacy at the same time
with dashlane you'll be alerted if any
of your accounts or data are breached it
also has a dark web monitoring system
that will immediately let you know if
your personal information appears on the
dark web where it can be seen by hackers
or spammers but wait is this safe what
if - Lane gets hacked well it's actually
safer to put all your passwords into -
Lane then if not using the password
manager - lanes safely stores and
decrypt your data on your local device
only using your master password so in
the rare instance that a hacker did
breach - Lane
they wouldn't even be able to see your
password because not even - Lane has the
keys to decrypt them from my experience
- Lane is the best all bases covered
security and time-saving tool out there
and if you visit my unique promo link in
the description you can get a free
premium trial of - Lane for 30 days plus
if you enter 42 at checkout you will get
10% off - Lane premium thanks for
watching and thanks again to - Lane for
sponsoring this video don't forget to
check them out using the link below